alguna vez has trazado figuras
geométricas a partir de un círculo vamos
a intentarlo
esta es una figura que no tiene ángulos
pero su circunferencia mide 360 grados
vamos a comprobarlo utilizando tu juego
de geometría así que pausa el vídeo y ve
por escuadras regla transportador compás
lápiz goma y algunas hojas de papel
te voy a enseñar cómo trazar un
triángulo usando el compás el
transportador y una de las escuadras
primero trazamos un círculo
vamos a abrir nuestro compás cinco
centímetros así que tomamos nuestra
regla y lo medimos
vamos a trazar lo perfecto
el siguiente paso es dividir 360 entre 3
sabes porque exacto porque necesitamos
encontrar 3 puntos a lo largo de 360
grados de circunferencia hagamos nuestra
división 360 grados entre 3 son 120
grados
ahora identifiquemos los vértices de
nuestro triángulo
para ello con nuestra regla marcamos una
línea del centro a la orilla de aquí
partiremos para medir los primeros 120
grados y así encontraremos cada vértice
del triángulo hacemos una pequeña marca
y trazamos otra línea medimos otros 120
grados y volvemos a trazar otra línea y
así encontramos los tres vértices de
nuestro triángulo
vamos a marcarlos uniendo los puntos o
mejor dicho sus vértices
listo terminamos nuestro triángulo
si observamos detenidamente vemos que el
triángulo que formamos es equilátero
porque todos sus ángulos y lados miden
lo mismo
hagamos otro círculo solo que ahora
vamos a trazar un hexágono
en lugar de dividir 360 entre 3 lo
haremos entre 6 porque el hexágono tiene
6 lados y necesitamos encontrar 6 puntos
en la circunferencia 360 entre 6 son 60
realizaremos el mismo procedimiento que
con el triángulo medimos 60 grados con
el transportador marcamos y trazamos una
línea y así sucesivamente
ya que tenemos los vértices marcados los
unimos con líneas para definir el
hexágono
ves es muy fácil
trazamos un cuadrado hacemos nuestro
círculo y dividimos 360 grados entre 4
que nos da 90 grados
mira en ambas escuadras uno de los lados
mide 90 grados así que podemos
utilizarlas en lugar del transportador
para trazar nuestro cuadrado
tomemos esta que tiene forma de
triángulo escaleno y trazamos los
vértices del cuadrado
vaya qué rápido fue ahora unamos los
vértices con la misma escuadra
un tip puedes trazar distintas líneas
paralelas con diferentes ángulos de
inclinación empleando las escuadras solo
toma tus escuadras y colócala una sobre
otra para realizar los trazos
con este procedimiento pues trazar
figuras como triángulos cuadrados
pentágonos y muchas figuras más combina
diferentes figuras trazos y maneras de
utilizar tu juego de geometría